>>> INAD, THE WHCCELERATING
EXE SUS  BNGO
LIKE.VOCANDIDAT AK TH
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION H
FIZE THA ENT BIDEN'S EVENTUAL
NOR UPCOMING
COMA BATTLE.
THERLSO GROWININTEREST IN ANOTH.
ASA BROWN  CRITICS
GINNIEE OF
CLARENCE THO QUENS
JUSTICE.D
>> SHE'S BEE
AC
>> THEECAGANN
WING.
>> SIGNING O THIER ATIVESO HOUS
LE MNG
THE
ONE MAER THAT LETTJUSTICE THOMAL
PU DIS.
NO JUSTICETHED FORME
PRESIDENT TRUMP'QUESTOTHE HAERMH
NATIAL E.FOR HIS T.
>> THERE AREY SUBSTANTIV
REASONS CO WIT
JURISPRUDENCHY
THOMAS TO NO
.
R FOO ARE ALREAD
SKEPTICAL OF THE COURT, FOR
DEEPLYITICALION, TACE
INVOLVEMT  ALARM S
BELLS.
THEY GO BACS INCLUDING
ASUBMITTING A LI OF SUPPOSEDLY .
WITH THE STOTHE STEAS  BSSAC  U
EDE VIEN AT E  CAPITOL.VEN THE
TH RLICT, CRITICY JU
HIMSELF INASG
THITTEE USE OF HIS WS ACTIVISM
NDERS SAY SHE HAS EVERY
RIT TOEAD HER OW AND
SEE NO RY THVE A BEARI O
IF SHE'STYSE.
THERE IS NO INDICAON SHE HAS A
FINANC IN CA
COURT.
>> CLARENCS NOVIEWS HEOLDSSE O
JUSTICES WILL HAVE SPOUSES
HAVES BENVD ENGAGED.
ICERS OF THE SUPME
BECAUSE OF GINNIorter: BS
ANOTHER ISSUE RE
N THVISORY BOARDATIVGROUP.
SCHOLARS.ASSOCIATIONL
THEY SUBMITTED TWOEG
TO THE SUPRE COURT IR OF
PLAINTIFFS CHALLENON AND
ADMISSIONST O UNIVERSITIES.
PETER WOOD IS PRESIDENORGANIZATD
NOOLE HE B
>> KNOW, DW THLE BRIE A H>> Rep
CALLINFO'
HIS WIFES CLOSELY AFCTICE,HE
WITH AN PORTIOATAKPOSITIONMSTO .
>> Reporter: THE F
ATY  JUDGE O
DISQUALIFYIM
D N ICH HIPARTIALITY MIGHTY
INDENDTHT..T E OF TO D THE IS N
BE ON ONE TEAM OOTIN
IN ORDERATH
OUE.>> SOME EX
OUT TO EXPLAIN THE DECISTOE OR
GINNI AS' ACTIVISM STAND
GROUP.ST TE SPOUSEOFJOOBTSJANE N
GINSBURG BECAMT COUR HUSBANDS